one day i'll get you out of this
i promise
attention the champion has been
eliminated
there's something wrong with my gun
what's she doing here
[Music]
you need to go home
forget about me
it's the only way you'll be safe
warning
ring closing
we'll head to the banker resupply
we should get to high ground that's what
my mom always says what is the syndicate
thinking i letting a pup join the guy
i'm a human person you should stay here
at cypher we're not leaving her we're a
team and we look out for each other sure
it's our funeral
[Music]
is it true did you do the things they
said
of course not but all that matters here
is what people believe
it's my fault you're in here isn't it
if only i'd listen we all make our own
choices
i'm here because of mine
i'll get you out
all right
i can handle them you are my everything
child if you end up here it would
destroy me guards we're done here no
i won't believe you
i'll get you out of this
not bad shooting
i was supposed to look after you
not the other way around we're a team
we look after each other
we have a winner
i did this for my mom zenia completa
she's been wrong
good start my wild one
dangerous